[Music]
[Music]
for me
finally some service Jesus do you have
any jackets without a British god I look
kind of like Twiggy holding me who are
you oh that I'm sterling Archer world's
greatest spy
you probably shouldn't tell people
you're a spy then what's the point in
being one fair enough
listen I'm legally blind got it but no I
don't want to donate what the glasses
you've looked like my eighth grade shop
teacher charming listen mate I'm gonna
need you to leave where did you get
those oh there's this super cool secret
room you gotta check it out are the
Kingsmen allowed in there huh the guys
who've sang Louie Louie put the gear
back no excuse me
are you blind and deaf I said no or I'm
done being polite doesn't being polite
are your governor I see say you a
gamblin man mr. Archer well I wrote the
underground here so you tell me
well then care to engage in the most
gentlemanly of competitions Turkish oil
wrestling what no you [ __ ] a drinking
contest standard Queensbury rules each
man imbibe in a shop so this is what
passes for the world's greatest spy in
America oh no need to go to and teach
him a lesson
but first I'm gonna draw a knob on your
face
we're from the Kings montañés shop in
London maybe you've heard of us
today marks the beginning of a new age
I'm gonna show you to the Kingsmen
carnival a bit of a save the world
situation here
welcome to States me is your American
cousins we'll be working side by side
let's get started
we've got brains skills skipping-rope
[Music]
to lasso whatever
[Applause]
[Music]
it's very American yeah it is
[Music]
manners make it a man do you know what
that means
[Music]